design can help us create meaningful
relationships between people and its
built environment
hi I'm Hans I'm the curator and the
founder of alpha repair
[Music]
Alpha repair was an exhibition that we
made in 2020 and 2021 what we did was to
commission 10 designers and each of them
repaired creatively and object
volunteered from the public I wanted to
create some tension between object and
designer so that we could create
unexpected outcomes
so one of the projects that I was really
surprised of was the repair of those
broken spectacles by kinetic what they
did was instead of repairing the
spectacles they 3D printed the Torso and
the head of the owner and manipulated
the head to fit the broken spectacles
instead
for me this piece of work is really
important for the exhibition because it
showed the different dimension of what
repair could do
sometimes when things are broken it is
our seeing and our thinking that needs
to be revitalized or repaired and not
just the object in itself
gremlin's repair process for this object
was quite fascinating with his
conversations as the owners he learned
the story behind the memory of the clock
and how it was important to the owners
so what he did was to ask both of them
to contribute 11 coats of their time
together so by gesture control you could
trigger these 11 messages that would
appear randomly and it will remind them
of the time together
[Music]
in the second iteration we had designers
based in the UK repairing objects from
Singapore and vice versa and the
outcomes were exhibited at the Victorian
Albert Museum and for us that was really
important because it was the first time
a curator concept of idea from Singapore
was accepted and exhibited at one of the
world's leading Museum of other design
this project is really important for me
because it is a response to this
hyper-consumer risk culture that we have
and I think repair is a very important
element to think about because if you
are able to repair and object
meaningfully and restore not just this
function but also to add a different
layer of meaning to it in terms of a
relationship between the owner and the
object I think that becomes something
new and that's I think what design and
creativity can offer foreign
[Music]